Good morning Hank it's Friday, I'm going to do Alex Day's Youtube survey, but quickly four things
First:
Balls, balls, balls, ball, b-b-b-b-balls
Balls, balls, balls, balls, balls, b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b-b
Balls, balls!
You said "balls" a lot in your last video
Second: Team 6 for life!
Third: our secret sister, Maureen Johnson, aka Actual John Green
had her best book ever: The Name of the Star come out yesterday
I am very excited about this book because everybody is gonna love it!
Fourth: Hank, did you know that Nerdfighters have loaned more than $55,000
to entrepreneurs in the developing world through Kiva?
French the Llama! $55,000!
Hank, I am once again reminded that Nerdfighters are made of awesome
So, every year Alex Day does a survey- well, this is the first year, but it's you know, gonna be every year
"Tell us about your first kiss"
I assume you mean French kiss
In that case, it was at summer camp
Summer camp was kinda like the internet before the internet was the internet
Like, at summer camp you were cooler and better looking
Than you were in were irl
Hank, you might have heard this story before
but I had a girlfriend, her name was Tiffany,
and we had a candlelight ceremony
on the last night of camp.
Hank, looking back I'm not even sure I would call it kissing;
It was kinda like facial-licking.
But anyway, we had this candelight ceremony
And we both knew that we wanted to French,
we'd discussed it previously.
Everybody's crying cause camp about to end,
you gotta go back to your irl life where you aren't nearly as cool
And I walk up to Tiffany and I wrap my arms around her
and I start just you know,
licking her face
And, uh, eventually
I start to smell the fact that my hair is on fire
because I got my arm so far wrapped around her
the candle is like, lighting my hair
and it's burning
and... yeah.
My second kiss, came three years later
"Most expensive casual item of clothing every bought"
Definitely this suit, which I had to buy so I wouldn't look like a dumb*ss
standing next to my wife at the Venice biennale.
Of course, Hank, some will say that this suit isn't casual
in which case, my most expensive article of causal clothing
is probably my Team 6 for life t-shirt
"What was the first job you ever wanted as a kid?"
I don't know remember this Hank,
but when we were little, I really wanted an earthworm scientist
like a professional studier of earthworms
I guess because it mixed my two talents of animal husbandry and science
"Tell us about your group of school friends!"
I was a nerd, but for my last three years of high school, I went to a really nerdy boarding school
and there I wasn't really a nerd
I was kinda like, a trouble-maker.
I'm so embarrassed to have this secret, non-nerdy past!
"What would you name your kids?"
How do you know you're too old for Youtube?
You've already named a kid.
I really wanted to name Henry "Gatsby,"
but then Sarah was like "We can't name our child "Gatsby"!"
She was like, "He's a tragic character; you don't want our child to end up like Gatsby!"
But I was like, "No, no! Gatsby turned out all right at the end;
it is what preyed on Gatsby, what foul dust trailed in the wake of his dreams"
I actually wanted to put that quote over his crib.
"Who do you want to answer the survey next?"
Everybody can leave survey responses here or at Nerimon's video
but I really want my brother
to answer the survey, my brother, Hank Green, whom I will see on Monday!
[singsong] My chair's so spinny, it's a spinny, spinny chair!
I promised Nerdfighteria I wouldn't sing anymore
[normal voice] I'm sorry